люди гуляють wool & team та мирно подивитися
кращого місця
донецьк над сфотал за все менший нервово
ви на хуста їх my city
volter old ях ну і моніка гра ви часто
пари для дають всі фотографії puppey
рудого youth завантаживши що потребує їх як
їм іван і багатий уроки
краплі фальші друзі на що давно
написали нам ті в серпанку били аеропорту
за рунова ну осі ми 20 рокки в дупу
молодим людям чого тількін і привозив і
Сем Арну вона нічого сподіваюся раніше он і
регулярно видав і до донецька допомагала
він пах злодіям дітям пенсіонерам мало за
безтурботний їм людям постраждав їм видно
цис му
звуком і у творився справжній дружній
сумки фотографії лай стив до сувеніри
все навка місяць року apple у друзів у на
донбасі
алавіт коли коливалася even a volte road
to моніка по трапу ти в будиночку не може
в селі тох він обрав і допомогу сара 4 в
бух розуму серпня ось я йду потреб їх
виявилося а праворуч ним ви пробування
days ванни риба була устілки всього зуби
ти вранці це різанини доза була в
українських міністерствах cs опусти на
затягувалося а клуб же не все папи
розібрав і планувалося паршивець правда
гуманітарну друга рудня пожер нам про
three mall вапну що на найвищій до
їх із міністерських до звали
потім я волосся ще одна проблема а буде
правда гуманітарну допомогу того щоб
нашим ступенем театром бу в німецькій
червоною христу та цифри тому що тебе
установка за голій жадібну цю сумку до
нашої ініціативи він і молодець її батька
антонову річкових свят та сліди кільку
суміш цих теанін і допомога наріжте
вид права лося на донбас вангажі
найвдалішою президента теплою ковдрою
з прямо вали
до маріуполя гаранту в 11 та доставку до
донецька виявилося не чоловікові його в
маріуполі
духом scudo помелу 1 поділити між
машинами переселенцями
організатори сподіваються що друзям у
гості передати про найм обсі днища
старим і хвороба людям йти не може
виїхати з донецька
новими про гуманітарну катастрофу на
донбасі
торгуєте мешканці вохма то можеш чорну
став відома править правку монтажу до
бухти на склад прийшли десятки людей
експорт липучку ну ви щодо ситуації в
донецьку подвоїли ваш com там розуму ви вирішили
на фільм ще бізнес може трахатись чіка
ти їм і зло вам про добрі права колонка
умань на бст їхній новий особистий montage
guide право тобто в україну обухом тих
але суть нові покупки резервним
вкладам для гуманітарної допомоги
that i then послугу та гараж монік ігрова
розум звай trout геть і створив і адже
взявся за форму немає числа них по парі
для нас тут його vantage у зинки вірити
що рану дж і листа донецька поверніть
паперового жити а